this is our home now i want us to
fit in oh darling we do
we shall hey everyone carlos here okay
so first things first
a warning to those who have not seen
juan division yet we will be getting
into some spoiler territory here so guys
you
do you want to do the throw up the thing
and the yeah
there it is all right good so please go
check out the show for yourself and then
come back here
we'll talk about what in the multiverse
you just saw
okay
[Music]
four weeks now we've been watching the
one division trailer saying to ourselves
we just don't know what to expect and
quite frankly after those first two
episodes
we still kind of don't 23 films on in
the mcu and i think it's fair to say
loyal viewers got used to the idea of
trying to predict the plot twists
surprise character reveals and epic
moments but
how are we supposed to get a read on
what comes next when we're used to this
[Music]
but we're getting this i bring you
the magnetic questions
the cabinet of mysteries yeah it's what
she said
by the way vision doing a magic show
drunk on chewing gum is
my new favorite marvel moment i'm doing
it
now if you've never seen a minute of
those old black and white sitcoms
admittedly it might take a while for it
to sink in
that the team behind wand division is
really going for it the set
the writing the performances it really
does feel as though you're watching a
show from the 1950s
elizabeth olsen's wanda channels the
magical charm of the witch
one perfectly us should really determine
the source of that sound
yes one other should and just as i
predicted catherine han steals
every scene she's in as the nosy
neighbor agatha heart
i mean agnes there's even a moment where
vision makes sure not to trip over the
living room ottoman dick van dyke style
and of course there's the opening theme
[Music]
song
the true beauty of this concept though
comes across when you remember
that this is a marvel property featuring
marvel characters one of whom died twice
in the same movie
yet he is right there in black and white
someone's drawn a little hard
right above today's day oh yes the heart
the mystery starts right off the bat
with this scene where wanda and vision
can't quite remember
why this date is highlighted on their
calendar and the first two episodes are
filled with moments like these
strongly suggesting that some seriously
dark stuff is going on just out of view
westview that is so who is behind all
this
fans of the comics will know that
wanda's powers give her the ability to
create entire realities
but if that's the case what's with the
commercials that clearly point to a
hydra connection
and let's not forget about the shady
figure literally watching wanda envision
sitcom life
at the end of the first episode so
there's no apparent super villain and no
big action set piece to hook viewers in
but as tiana paris told me one division
will be a show that rewards
patience what's interesting about you
know one division is that that whole
thing about the fighting and the action
i mean we don't get that right off the
bat were you surprised about the
direction that this show was
was going to take when they first told
you about it you you don't get it right
off the bat
but what i love about wanda vision is
that
it is infusing um you know it is an
homage to american television across the
decades and
it does infuse that big epic marvel
movie production in there you just have
to
hang tight until you get there and you
figure out
what's going on um all the little things
that are being revealed
so after everything we just saw in the
first two episodes we're left with way
more questions than answers
like what's up with the voice in the
radio wanda
who's doing this team
who the heck is this guy why do i want
one of these toasters so bad
the all-new toastmate 2000 by stark
industries
forget the past this is your future
and who if anyone at all in west view
really knows
what's going on okay so we know there
are all sorts of theories floating
around and honestly
that's half the fun so if you think you
know what's coming up next or which
surprise characters are going to show up
let's talk about it in the comments
below i'll give you a free one right now
people are saying evan peters will play
mephisto or a new version of quicksilver
my money's on him playing a grown
grown-up tommy maximoff you know
tommy shepard anyway coming back to nerd
alert next week for the episode 3
breakdown and if you feel like getting
real nerdy with it
i had a division in scarlet witch info
episode with comic book issue numbers
and
everything uh you can probably watch it
you know
right here okay take care folks i'll see
you next time
[Music]
is that too high for right here how
about right here
how about right there not that
there is this i'm imagining that there's
a box here
watch it right here i wonder what the
what the thumbnail will be